bien nous allons commencer
cette soirée événement et peut-être que
chacun pourrait trouver sa place
j'espère
que nous avons mais je pense qu'on doit
avoir à cette place normalement nos
services
on fait un bon calcul chacun peut
trouver et les bien sûr les intervenants
pourront se placer
dès qu'ils le courant sur la tribu
bien Votre Majesté Impériale Phara pas
la vie
Votre Altesse Impériale prince Nour je
vais vous faire part de la fierté qui
est la nôtre
ce soir de vous accueillir ici au Sénat
votre présence est un honneur c'est un
grand honneur et elle donne encore plus
de poids au message de soutien qu'à
travers cette conférence nous voulons
adresser à votre peuple et à toutes
celles qui incarnent la force et la
grandeur de sa civilisation c'est
courageux iranienne qui ont fait se
lever en Iran le grand vent de la
liberté je vais aussi saluer et
remercier tous nos intervenants pour
traiter de cette question si brûlante et
nous avons eu réunir des universitaires
des journalistes des juristes qui sont
tous reconnus pour leurs compétences
dans leur domaine respectifs vous me
permettrez aussi de remercier mes
collègues sénateurs et j'en ai vu de
nombreux sur tous les bancs ici de cette
amphithéâtre Médicis vraiment merci et
saluer aussi la présence prochaine de ma
collègue Annick brillant qui est
aujourd'hui retenu à l'instant même où
je vous parle dans l'hémicycle pour un
certain nombre comment dirais-je de
discussion mais surtout d'amendement
qu'elle doit présenter pour la
délégation au droit des femmes mais nous
avons organisé ensemble cette
manifestation cette conférence d'un côté
donc la délégation au droit des femmes
qui est présidé par Annie billon
qui sénatrice et sénatrice de Vendée
voyez et de l'autre côté donc le groupe
de liaison que je préside pour les
chrétiens et les minorités au
Moyen-Orient car au-delà des différentes
confessions des différences convulsions
que connaît le Moyen-Orient le combat
que mène notre groupe de liaison est
d'abord et avant tout un combat pour la
liberté des peuples et pour la dignité
des personnes c'est le combat courageux
des femmes iraniennes et cette
conférence cette d'abord et aussi un
hommage au courage
au courage de toutes ces femmes qui en
République islamique d'Iran haute leur
voile au risque qu'on leur haute la vie
courage total parce que ça n'est pas
seulement un courage moral c'est aussi
un courage physique courage national
aussi puisque c'est désormais à
l'échelle de toute une nation toute une
nation que la contestation s'exprime et
que le régime réprime près de 500 morts
près de 500 morts dont une soixantaine
d'enfants et plus de 16000 arrestations
selon les dernières estimations
chiffrées depuis la mort de Macha Amini
impressionnantation par la police des
mœurs en septembre dernier la République
islamique applique en grand
la politique sur laquelle se fonde tous
les régimes fondamentalistes la terreur
la terreur est avec elle c'est
soi-disant terroristes puisque c'est
ainsi que l'Iran des Mollat qualifie ses
vrais résistantes héroïne à la tête nue
qui se dresse face au tyran en turban
femme vit liberté ces mots scandés par
des milliers de cœurs Iraniens sont
évidemment insupportables pour la
République islamique et ne nous y
trompons pas ces mots d'espoir les
disciples de comédie sont prêts à les
recouvrir du sang de l'Iran pour les
effacer les effacer définitivement
il n'y parviendront pas mais en
attendant la terreur fait son œuvre et
le tribunal révolutionnaire lui fait sa
loi celle du crime atterhéran il a déjà
prononcé plusieurs condamnations à mort
contre les participants au mouvement
nous sommes en face d'un pouvoir
totalité et nous le savons depuis un art
rent la mesure du totalitarisme
précisément c'est sa démesure pour lui
tout est permis pour lui tout est
possible alors que faire que faire quand
les indignations n'atteignent pas un
régime que l'idée même de la dignité
humaine n'atteint pas installez le
rapport de force puisque c'est là le
seul langage que Téhéran comprend il
faut évidemment intensifier les
sanctions
intensifier toutes les sanctions non pas
sur le peuple iranien mais sur ces
bourreaux des premières mesures ont déjà
été prises elles doivent être renforcées
aux plans national au plan international
mais aussi au plan européen pour geler
les avoir des responsables impliqués
dans la répression et interdire toute ma
toute mise à disposition des fonds
évidemment de ses propres responsables
ces responsables qui sont impliqués et
je dois dire que ces sanctions doivent
aussi préoccuper toutes les technologies
tout ce qui peut servir d'armes qui
peuvent être exportées de France
d'Europe pour réprimer le peuple iranien
c'est un point qui est important et je
pense qu'il faudra aller aussi plus loin
pour déclarer terroristes un certain
nombre de milices de groupes liés au
régime a commencé évidemment par les
sinistres Gardiens de la Révolution oui
un rapport de force doit être installé
clairement installé
compris au sein des grands institutions
internationales pouvons-nous chers amis
accepter qu'à l'heure ou des femmes
iraniennes tombent sous les coups des
balles à Téhéran l'Iran sièges encore au
sein de la commission de l'ONU sur les
conditions des femmes pouvons-nous
l'accepter cette présence est une
indécente la France doit exiger
clairement comme l’ont déjà fait les
États-Unis le Canada que la République
islamique d'Iran ne siège plus dans
cette commission la France doit aussi
intervenir auprès du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU pour la saisine de la Cour
pénale internationale ou alors pour
saisir directement son procureur compte
tenu des crimes des crimes qui sont
désormais documentés des crimes qui sont
commis en Iran tout donc doit être tenté
sur le plan juridique et diplomatique
exigeons sans tarder sans répit
exigeons la protection du droit des
enfants dans la continuité de l'appel
récent de l'UNICEF du 10 octobre dernier
naturellement ce bras de fer avec l'Iran
la France doit aussi dans ce bras de fer
protégé ses propres ressortissants au
moment où je vous parle je vous rappelle
que cette française sont dans les jaunes
iraniennes et nous devons exiger bien
entendu leur libération comme la
libération de tous les autres
prisonniers de tous les autres
ressortissants qui sont détenus dans les
prisons d'Iran cette fermeté envers
l'Iran nous devons l'assumer et nous
déposerons d'ailleurs prochainement au
Sénat au nom de mon groupe parlementaire
et je l'espère d'autres groupes parce
que ce combat ne doit pas être un combat
partisan ça doit être un combat trans
partisan pour qu'il gagne en force
j'espère que d'autres groupes se
joindront à nous pour soutenir une
proposition de résolution qui
réaffirmera non seulement notre soutien
au mouvement en Iran mais qui renforcera
surtout qui renforcera les sanctions
contre le régime iranien
mais s'il nous faut assumer cette
fermeté et je veux qu'au Sénat nous
puissions la dire que nous puissions
l'affirmer que nous puissions la voter
il nous faut également affirmer une
vérité cette vérité que nous renvoie en
miroir les courageux iraniennes et qui
nous concerne directement nous les
Français nous les Européens car la
grande contestation qui s'est levée
là-bas en Iran tranche avec la grande
confusion qui parfois règne ici chez
nous sur le voile islamique et cette
confusion se change parfois en
capitulation lorsque la Commission
européenne fait la promotion du
programme Erasmus beau programme belle
réussite européenne à travers l'image
d'une jeune fille voilée c'est une
capitulation lorsque nous laissons
prospérer des discours politiques qui
présentent comme des discriminations
les lois de 2004 sur l'interdiction des
signes religieux à l'école ou la loi de
2010 qui prohib le ni cap dans l'espace
public c'est une capitulation et ce sont
des capitulations parce que c'est faire
en définitive le jeu d'anislam radical
d'anislam politique dont la stratégie
est claire retournez l'argumentaire
libéral contre notre démocratie
ce parait du voile de la liberté pour
voiler les femmes
certes toutes les femmes qui portent le
voile ne sont pas islamistes mais tous
les islamistes exigent des femmes
qu'elles portent le voile et qu'elle
soit violée voilée en Iran comme dans
nos territoires perdus par la République
et gagner par l'islamisme
le combat des iraniennes n'est donc pas
seulement exemplaire il est aussi
salutaire pour nous car en notant leur
voile elle déchire le notre ce voile
d'illusion d'un Occident qui a cru
servir la liberté en tolérant la
servissement par des accommodements des
raisonnables non le voile islamique
n'est pas et ne sera jamais un symbole
de liberté toujours il restera le
symbole d'une domination d'un sexe sur
un autre d'une séparation d'un groupe
sur les autres et je le dis c'est un
drame que tout un discours sur la
défense des minorités visibles pour
reprendre une expression que je n'aime
guère est conduit à banaliser ici chez
nous et même légitimer
l'invisibilisation des femmes alors oui
les Iraniennes ne forcent pas seulement
notre admiration
elle nous force aussi à l'introspection
et la leçon de vaillance doit être pour
nous un examen de conscience
qu'avons-nous fait de ce bel idéal de
liberté que notre civilisation a forgé
et puis porter
telle est aussi la question fondamentale
que nous lance aujourd'hui le peuple
iranien du fond de ses épreuves au cœur
de son combat ce combat est le nôtre
soyons aux côtés des combattants de la
liberté soyons le jusqu'à la victoire
elle viendra la victoire elle viendra
n'en doutez pas n'en doutons pas car si
l'histoire est parfois tragique elle est
toujours impitoyable toujours
impitoyable vis-à-vis des tyrans rien
n'arrête un peuple qui se bat pour sa
liberté contre les molas l'Iran se bat
contre les Melas l'Iran vaincra merci de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
voilà un joli mot c'est un mot qui veut
dire liberté et c'est un mot qui est ici
sans doute dans cette enceinte
parlementaire résonne particulièrement
puisque c'est en France finalement en
1789 que nous l'avons réinventé en
descendant dans la rue comme les
Iraniens et les Iraniennes aujourd'hui
descendent dans la rue d'ailleurs quand
on parle aux Iraniens il nous le
rappelle au nom de cette liberté chaque
jour en Iran depuis des semaines des
femmes des femmes surtout mais aussi des
jeunes des étudiants des scolaires des
enfants de plus en plus jeunes et des
hommes aussi qui se mettent au devant
des femmes se font arrêter emprisonnés
torturé exécuter par un régime aux abois
chaque jour en Iran on ramasse des corps
dans la rue
tout ça bien sûr on le sait puisque les
actualités nous le montrent l'actualité
urgente mais en réalité qu'est-ce qu'on
sait vraiment de l'Iran dans toutes ses
composantes géographiques ethniques
sociales politique religieuse culturelle
qu'est-ce qui se passe vraiment à
Téhéran à isparant ailleurs est-ce que
c'est une révolte est-ce que c'est une
révolution si c'est une révolution quel
avenir c'est à toutes ces questions que
ce soit nous allons essayer de répondre
grâce à nos invités le premier d'entre
eux est un journaliste français
d'origine iranienne Emmanuel razavie et
grands reporter essayiste
documentariste et il travaille depuis
des années sur les différents mouvements
d'opposition en Iran Emmanuel
merci infiniment
monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
Votre Majesté princesse Nour
prince Daoud mesdames et messieurs
je voudrais si vous le permettez avant
d'évoquer le contexte dramatique que
connaît l'Iran rappelez que nos deux
pays sont liés depuis le 17e siècle
époque à laquelle Louis XIV reçut le
premier émissaire officiel d'un roi de
Perse
depuis les relations entre l'Iran et la
France se sont inscrites dans la durée
les deux pays pouvant je le crois une
fascination mutuelle
on se souvient des récits de voyage de
Pierre Loti d'autres écrivains voyageurs
français racontant magnifiquement Shiraz
les jardins disparants la culture
persane qui les impressionnait de temps
plus près de nous après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la France et l'Iran
coopérer dans des domaines comme la
culture l'économie avec les succès que
l'on connaît
aussi ce soir je veux voir dans ce qui
nous rassemblent ici la promesse d'un
nouveau chemin à parcourir pour nos deux
pays malgré toute l'inquiétude qui est
la nôtre lorsque nous voyons la terrible
répression dont sont victimes les
manifestants iraniens
rappelons que depuis le mois de
septembre des centaines de personnes ont
été tuées par le régime
que plus de 16000 sont détenus dans les
jolies
dans ces prisons elle subissent les
passages à tabac
les viols les tortures
je voudrais aussi rappeler que bien
avant que les Mollans ne sont pas du
pouvoir en 1979 et qu'ils imposent leur
dogmes funeste les Iraniens ont été en
pointe en matière des droits des femmes
ainsi l'impératrice est-elle engagé
durant plusieurs années en faveur de
leur égalité avec les hommes
ainsi qu'en faveur de l'accès à
l'éducation pour tous ces succès en la
matière furent considérables
43 ans après l’avènement de la
République islamique c'est courageux
Iraniens qui défile le régime depuis le
mois de septembre porte eux aussi ses
valeurs universelles d'égalité et de
liberté si chers à la France
l'Iran vit bien sûr l'un des moments les
plus dramatiques de son histoire
contemporaine mais il vit aussi un
formidable moment d'espoir car les
Iraniens le disent tous il n'y aura plus
de retour en arrière
car le régime iranien est en Pétré dans
le déni incapable de répondre aux
attentes de son peuple autrement que par
la violence autrement que par les
assassinats cela les Iraniens ne
l'accepteront plus jamais
ceux qui ont pris le pouvoir en Iran en
79 ne connaissait rien la gouvernance
d'un pays il n'avait pas davantage
d'intérêt pour la nation iranienne
ostracisant persécutant tous ceux qui ne
pensaient pas comme eux
ainsi depuis 43 ans l'Iran a connu
plusieurs mouvements de contestation à
chaque fois réprimer dans le sang ce fut
le cas en 2009 en 2017 en 2019
le régime islamique en réalité fait du
terrorisme d'État l'un de ses piliers
créant des milices paramilitaires
mafieuses à l'instar des Gardiens de la
révolution qui ont fauté tant
d'attentats contre leurs opposants à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur du pays
à cette violence c'est ajouter la
corruption qui a conduit le pays
pourtant riche en pétrole fort d'une
culture plusieurs fois millénaire au
bord de l'abîme
c'est dans ce contexte dramatique à
émerger une nouvelle révolte en
septembre dernier après le meurtre de
Massa mini pour mauvais port du voile
une révolte qui prend la forme je le
crois ces dernières semaines d'une
révolution
une révolution qui se déroule en ce
moment dans les rues de Téhéran de
machad disparu et qui est sans précédent
sans précédent d'abord parce que ce sont
des femmes qui la portent des femmes qui
se battent pour les droits humains
ensuite parce que la jeunesse iranienne
qui les soutient combat les tenants d'un
islam politique islam politique qui
cherche à étendre sa toile partout dans
le monde
un islam politique qui a fait de son
étendard le voile islamique un moyen
d'asservissement des femmes considérés
comme des êtres inférieurs par les
Mollat
cette révolution qui s'étend à tout le
pays intervient aussi dans un moment
particulier car avec une inflation de
40%, l'Iran connaît une crise économique
sans précédent
le chômage fera plus d'un tiers de la
population quand des familles ne
parviennent plus à donner de repas par
jour à leurs enfants
rappelons aussi qu'en raison d'une
corruption endémique des barrages ont
été construits un peu partout à travers
le pays dans des régions qui n'en
n'avaient pas besoin et que tout cela
ajoutait au climat semi aride d'une
partie de l'Iran a fait que des millions
d'Iraniens n'ont plus accès à l'eau
potable parfois même à l'électricité
depuis 43 ans tous ceux qui ont tenté de
faire entendre leur voix pour dénoncer
les dérives du régime ont été battus
arrêtés parfois tués encore ces
dernières semaines des enfants de 10 14
15 ans ont été assassinés dans la rue
par les gardiens de la révolution bras
armé de la République islamique
on se demande bien quel était leur faute
oui en 43 ans les millions d'Iraniens
ont été confrontés directement ou
indirectement à l'humiliation des
arrestations arbitraires à la torture
aux assassinats de proches parmi eux des
membres de minorités dans les provinces
où vivent Kurdes ou Baluch également
victimes de terribles exactions
aujourd'hui la jeunesse iranienne dit
stop elle ne veut plus du régime
théocratique qui sévit à terre
la jeunesse iranienne particulièrement
éduquée réclame la liberté
le droit de vivre celui de travailler
comme n'importe qui dans une démocratie
la France vieille compagne de l'Iran
doit entendre les appels de ses Iraniens
qui ont besoin de son soutien
parmi eux il existe des gens venus qui
viennent pardon de différents horizons
capables de construire un nouvel Iran il
faut parier sur eux les aider leur
donner les moyens de s'unir
car ils incarnent la promesse d'un Iran
libre d'un Iran Pacifique gage de
stabilité pour le Moyen-Orient gage de
stabilité pour le monde entier car il
défendent aussi des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres liberté égalité fraternité
pour terminer je voudrais ce soir rendre
hommage à saisir un lien qui se battent
pour ses valeurs en prononçant ces
quelques mots que vous avez déjà tous
entendu ces dernières semaines que le
président d'ailleurs a prononcé tout à
l'heure Zam zen Deguy azadis ce qui veut
dire en français femme vie liberté
[Applaudissements]
merci
il n'y aura pas dites-vous de retour en
arrière la révolte est devenue une
révolution le régime Vinci sur quoi
repose encore ce régime est-ce qu'il
repose sur la peur qui depuis 43 ans
contamine la société ankylose et endort
les consciences et l'esprit de révolte
ou est-ce qu'il peut encore compter sur
de solides force de répression alors
déjà pour répondre à la première
question
Jean-Marie je fais depuis deux mois et
demi des dizaines et des dizaines
d'interviews par semaine en fait
d'Iraniens d'Iraniens de l'intérieur
d'iranienne des jeunes des moins jeunes
toutes générations tous disent sans
exception qu'ils ne veulent plus du
régime des molles là donc ce que je dis
là ce soir repose non pas sur ce que je
pense mais repose sur ce que les
Iraniens de la rue me racontent à moi
journaliste
ce régime pour répondre à la deuxième
question c'est un régime qui aujourd'hui
est dans le déni c'est un régime qui n'a
jamais su répondre aux attentes de la
population iranienne depuis qu'il est
arrivé je l'ai rappelé dans le
l'intervention que je viens de faire à
plusieurs reprises les Iraniens sont
descendus dans la rue pacifiquement pour
faire entendre leur voix à plusieurs
reprises les Iraniens ont demandé très
pacifiquement qu'on les écoute ils se
sont fait tirer dessus ils ont été
arrêtés je l'ai dit dans mon
intervention torturé
aujourd'hui la violence les assassinats
le viol qui est aussi l'arme du régime
sont devenus en fait les seuls moyens je
pense de tenir pour ce régime qui est à
bout de souffle c'est en tout cas moi ce
que je perçois dans le cadre de mes
enquêtes et oui je pense que ce régime
aujourd'hui ne pourra pas tenir très
longtemps car on ne tient pas un pays
aussi éduqué que l'Iran à coup de
matraque de kalachnikov et de violence
quelle qu'elle soit
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un printemps
iranien comme on a parlé d'un printemps
arabe alors c'est une question que on
entend beaucoup actuellement je vais
vous donner ma perception moi je ne
crois pas qu'il s'agisse en fait d'un
qu'on puisse le comparer un printemps
arabe j'ai plutôt l'impression
d'ailleurs que ce sont les Iraniens en
2009 quand un peu inspiré quand même ce
qui s'est passé dans le monde arabe
et je pense aussi qu'il y a une chose
qui est importante l'Iran tout le monde
ne le sait pas mais n'est pas un pays
arabe et donc là la façon de penser des
Iraniens de ces jeunes Iraniens de ces
jeunes iraniennes leur sociologie leur
culture est très différente de celle que
l'on peut connaître dans le monde arabe
que j'aime beaucoup comme vous le savez
Jean-Marie donc c'est très différent
donc je suis toujours gêné par cette
appellation en fait de printemps arabe
qui voudrait nous rappeler ce qui s'est
passé il y a une dizaine d'années il y a
un autre point qui est très important
ces jeunes Iraniens combattent l'islam
politique en Iran il faut se rappeler
que pendant les printemps arabes les
Frères musulmans j'ai couvert les
printemps arabes donc je peux en parler
les Frères musulmans les islamistes se
sont engouffrés immédiatement dans la
brèche des manifestations pour pas
tomber les dictateurs aujourd'hui ces
jeunes iraniennes ces jeunes Iraniens
combattent l'islames politiques et je
crois que ce combat doit nous inspirer
très sincèrement en Occident je le dis
tout à l'heure parce qu'au moment où
l'islam politique s'implante de plus en
plus en France mais pas que en France
voilà la les Iraniennes les Iraniens
sont en train de faire tomber je crois
l'un de ses fers de lance
merci merci à vous la parole peut
évidemment circuler si quelqu'un veut
poser une question à Emmanuel Razavi
pas encore alors nous allons accueillir
maintenant si vous voulez bien madame
azadecchian ah pardon excusez-moi pardon
oui
il y a un bouton rouge je suis d'origine
égyptienne Franco égyptienne pour la de
l'homme et vous avez fait la comparaison
avec ce qui se passait au printemps
arabe
je me souviens 2011 en Egypte donc le
printemps arabe c'est c'est quel pays la
Tunisie et puis le la Libye l'Egypte
donc les Frères musulmans comme vous
l'avez dit ce sont engouffrés dans les
jeunes qui ces images que vous avez
passé tout à l'heure nous rappelle la
place tarir en 2011
et la prise de pouvoir a été faite par
les Frères musulmans et heureusement
qu'il y a eu la réveil deux ans plus
tard mais le réveil 2 ans plus tard
c'est parce qu'il y avait une armée et
finalement l'armée intervenue maintenant
ce qu'on voit en Iran quel est l'autre
pouvoir face à ces jeunes qui peuvent
les défendre et puis dire bon les mots
là doivent tomber mais qui prend la
place
infiniment monsieur pour votre question
alors j'ai découvert j'étais place tarir
donc je vois tout à fait de quoi vous
parlez j'ai beaucoup couvert l'Egypte
aujourd'hui en Iran c'est une question
qui se pose le rôle de l'armée on a pu
voir en fait certaines vidéos dans
certaines villes en fait de l'Iran dans
certaines villes italiennes ou des
militaires sont venus défendre de jeunes
manifestants
c'était assez ponctuel on a vu quelques
scènes aujourd'hui parmi l'armée
iranienne de ce que j'entends il y a
aujourd'hui oui des officiers qui se
posent la question du moment où il
basculeront en revanche ils ne sont pas
encore dans ce basculement je pense
qu'ils sont dans l'attente alors non pas
dans l'attente de ce que va faire le
peuple iranien parce qu'il le voit mais
dans l'attente de ce que va faire la
communauté internationale il y a deux
éléments qui sont importants de mon
point de vue mais à travers ce que
j'entends des témoignages que j'ai
chaque jour c'est que va faire la France
que vont faire les États-Unis deux pays
qui sont extrêmement importants en fait
pour l'Iran deux pays aujourd'hui qui je
crois qui résonne quand même aussi dans
le cœur en fait de ces Iraniens qui
manifestent et donc évidemment dans la
pensée en fait des militaires
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on s'en mêle aux
risques que finalement le régime ne
tombe pas et donc au risque d'être
fusillés que nos familles soient
arrêtées c'est ce que j'ai entendu voilà
ouf il y a une accélération de la
communauté internationale et là à ce
moment à ce moment précis donc nous
allons pouvoir montrer que nous
changeons de camp et que nous soutenons
en fait les jeunes même s'il y a déjà eu
quelques épisodes de la sorte voilà
c'est pas si j'ai répondu à votre
question
merci
madame madame azzadec
bonsoir
et ça lui est d'abord l'assemblée
remercier Monsieur retailleux d'avoir
organisé cette coloc ma question pour
compléter la
l'interrogation par rapport à la
similitude qu'on peut avoir avec le
printemps arabe il faut quand même
rappeler à l'assemblée que l'armée
iranienne n'est pas l'armée de laïque
fondée par Nasser depuis 43 ans il y a
eu un effort continu pour couper la tête
de l'armée entre guillemets comme nous
on peut l'imaginer ici et les remplacée
par les forces qui viennent des
passe-parents donc ce qu'on appelle nous
chez nous le sait pas donc il est
aujourd'hui très difficile de pouvoir
connaître ce qui se passe au centre de
l'armée parce que les fortes ont été les
forces ont été fusionnées avec les
milices de la révolution dont les têtes
sont nommées directement par le guide
suprême donc ça c'est une information
importante et je préfère rappeler
l'existence de Monsieur vos cinq Borély
qui est le chef de l'état-major iranien
et qui est directement nommé par romeni
donc c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de
penser que l'armée Thomas la nature quoi
la égyptienne pourrait reprendre le
dessus donc ça c'est assez difficile à
envisager mais pour le moment il y a
quelques signaux faibles comme vous
l'avez dit en attendant de voir s'ils
peuvent basculer parce que la communauté
internationale suit au moins on va dire
les officiers de rang inférieur
je partage tout à fait ce que vous venez
de dire Madame
totalement voilà moi je rapporte
aujourd'hui ce que j'entends lorsque je
discute évidemment avec des Iraniens
quel que soit je dirais leur
appartenance y compris d'ailleurs au
sein des milices des gardiens
merci Madame mazaki
vous êtes
sociologue professeur de sociologie vous
êtes directrice du Centre de
documentation et de recherche pour les
études féministes
on vous écoute
merci beaucoup
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs je suis
honoré d'être
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs vous
m'entendez
je suis honorée d'être ici parmi vous ce
soir
je
vais très rapidement faire tout d'abord
une présentation de l'Iran pour ce SL
qui
connaissent pas les particularités de ce
pays à savoir qu'il s'agit d'un ancien
empire que donc nous avons une mosaïque
ethno linguistique et religieuse c'est à
dire que c'est un pays multiethnique un
multi religieuse qui s'est constituée
sur plusieurs millénaires
donc c'est un pays qui est effectivement
se trouve à la croisée à la fois de
Moyen-Orient d'Asie d'Asie centrale et
donc de ce fait on l'Iran a beaucoup
aussi
influencé les courants civilisations à
la fois de monde iranien de mon indien
mais également de monde islamique en
général donc l'Iran était conquis par
les Arabes l'armée arabe au 7e siècle
donc
l'islamisation de l'Iran a duré pendant
plusieurs décennies voir siècle et donc
la religion zoroastrienne a c'était la
place à la religion musulmane et donc
au 16ème siècle sous les Safavides le
chiisme qui est aujourd'hui au pouvoir
en Iran devient la région religion de
l'État contre l'Empire ottoman qui était
euh le califat sunnite donc je vous
disais l'islam chiite majoritaire mais
il y a aussi une en Islam minoritaire à
savoir l'islam sunnite qui est à l'heure
actuelle très surveillé c'est très
difficile de vous dire combien de
pourcentage de la population est sunnite
puisque ça interdit lors des
recensements de poser cette question
mais selon mes enquêtes de terrain en
Iran jusqu'en 2008
j'estime avant pour cent le nombre des
sunnites en Iran essentiellement
constitué de des Kurdes de baloutes et
des turkmens ce sont les minorités
particulièrement à l'heure actuelle
aussi
réprimée puis il y a une grande d'autres
minorités religieuses à savoir justement
les chrétiens les juifs les héros astria
dont le nombre a beaucoup diminué
puisque la population iranienne a
pratiquement triplé depuis la Révolution
alors que le nombre des minorités
religieuses officiellement reconnue par
l'Islam n'a pas augmenté même à beaucoup
diminué et puis il y a une minorité les
baraïs qui n'ont absolument pas le droit
de citer qui sont particulièrement
persécutés puisque c'est une religion
interdite en Iran
alors c'est un pays qui se moderne nous
Emmanuel Razavi le disait
83 millions d'habitants 75% de la
population iranienne est urbaine et le
taux d'alphabétisation de l'ensemble de
la population et avoisine 90% c'est une
population relativement jeune disons par
rapport à la France par rapport aux
autres pays de la de la région
les Iraniennes donne naissance à l'heure
actuelle à seulement 1,6 enfants c'est
très important de le constater ce qui
montre aussi la modernisation de leur
comportement démocratique
et en même temps la majorité des
étudiants dans les université Iraniens
sont des étudiantes alors même qu'il y a
un concours d'entrée à l'université la
révolution actuelle doit beaucoup aussi
aux réseaux sociaux on le sait à
Internet c'est pour ça que il coupe
Internet et donc pratiquement 70% de la
population iranienne selon les
statistiques que j'ai pu trouver sont
effectivement ont accès Internet disons
avait accès maintenant le permettez-moi
de passer effectivement aux femmes
iraniennes c'est pas la première fois
que les femmes participent à un
mouvement social les femmes iraniennes
dès 1906 dès la Révolution
constitutionnelle ont participé à la
révolution sous une apparence voilée à
gauche qui a une quarantaine d'entre
elles a été d'ailleurs tuée et puis
aussi lors du mouvement pour la
nationalisation du pétrole elles ont
aussi soutenu ce mouvement puis très
rapidement je passe à la révolution de
79 à laquelle beaucoup de femmes
iraniennes ont participé sans
nécessairement avoir des revendications
pour leur propre droit alors ironie du
sort un mois à peine après la victoire
de la révolution et contrairement aux
promesses de homélie qui était leader de
la révolution le port du voile devient
obligatoire et une série de régressions
sont imposées au droit des femmes au
droit familial ce qui fait que de façon
automatique des milliers de femmes
descendant la rue de c'est l'image à
droite contre le port du voile
obligatoire et c'est régressions bien
sûr j'y étais et on a été tabassé donc
je pense que là il s'agit d'une société
moderne d'un côté avec un régime en face
qui est un régime moyenâgeux répressif
corrompu un meneur azzaville l'a dit il
faut vraiment insister là-dessus aussi
et en même temps
des lois et des institutions archaïques
qui effectivement place les femmes sous
la tutelle des hommes agis qui
considéraient réellement les femmes
comme des citoyennes de ce qu'onzone
j'ai pas le temps d'entrer dans les
détails et puis en 2009 lors des
mouvements verts les femmes surtout les
jeunes femmes participent à ce à ce
mouvement d'ailleurs n'oublions pas
Médard Soltane qui a été tué lors de ce
mouvement et donc là
femme égale homme était l'un des slogans
de ce mouvement enfin femme les femmes
iraniennes on le sait sont devenus les
enjeux politiques majeurs se sont elles
qui vont
défier qui ont défié ce régime à maintes
reprises et aujourd'hui fort
heureusement soutenu par aussi beaucoup
d'hommes et en particulier de jeunes
hommes après l'assassinat de Gina Massa
mini qui était comme une goutte qui a
fait débat déb et le vaste puisque leur
revendications étaient déjà là et
aujourd'hui les femmes sont au devant de
la scène contestataire et pour la
première fois dans ce pays je pense que
les hommes en particulier dans la jeune
génération ont bien compris que c'est
une révolution des femmes contre l'islam
politique et que tant que les femmes
n'aient pas obtenu l'égalité et bien on
ne peut pas parler d'un avenir
démocratique pour ce pays d'où
l'importance des combats des femmes et
de leur présence dans cette révolution
merci
merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
Kion Emmanuel razzaville vous nous avez
beaucoup parlé de répression pour
comprendre vraiment de quoi on parle je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter les
témoignages de d'anciens prisonniers du
régime iranien
si vous voulez bien approcher s'il vous
plaît merci
[Musique]
je trouve je pense que on va faire une
courte pause pour expliquer comment
fonctionne l'explications techniques et
elle doit désormais fonctionner alors je
crois qu'il faut appuyer sur un bouton
la régie va nous dire quel bouton sur
quel bouton appuyer
venez prenez le micro prenez le micro
non c'est pas ça c'est que elle a
donc ce sont les deux boutons qui sont à
droite de l'écran LCD pour sélectionner
les canaux
donc c'est le canal 1 le canal 1 si vous
faites par exemple sur le 2 ou le 3 vous
appuyez sur le bouton du bas avec la
flèche pointée vers le bas voilà vous
avez une oreille vous avez une oreille
entre et deux boutons et ça doit
fonctionner peut-on faire un test
au nom du dieu arc-en-ciel
très bien ça a l'air de marcher
et le volume le volume est à volume est
à gauche
ça fonctionne j'ai l'impression que ça
fonctionne oui pour tout le monde
merci
si vous pouviez recommencer dès le début
c'est la phrase
tout en jouant avec son petit bateau un
enfant de 10 ans vivant Alizée phrase
qui aujourd'hui est devenue la nouvelle
formule de la Révolution
était un enfant intelligent créatif et
très joyeux il y a quelques jours les
agents terroristes des Gardiens de la
Révolution ont tiré en salle sur la
famille de Kyan dans la rue
son père grièvement blessé et le
lendemain sa mère a été torturée
atrocement pour la forcer Annie et
publiquement la réalité de ce meurtre à
la télévision nationale du régime
parmi 65 enfants tués sauvagement par
des coups de matraque ou des balles
réelles
qui ne sont utilisés que durant la
guerre
dans les 43 dernières années une
majorité d'adolescents et de jeunes ont
vécu la terrible expérience d'une
arrestation de torture physique et
psychologique de répression et de
harcèlement et même de viol par les
agents de la police des mœurs
la première fois que j'ai été arrêtée
j'avais seulement 15 ans j'ai été
arrêtée parce que je jouais au
volley-ball avec les fils de mes voisins
la police des mœurs m'a inculpé je
prohibé selon la charia en me disant que
je n'avais même pas le droit de leur
adresser la parole
au commissariat ils m'ont menoter
tellement fort que je pleurais de
douleur les agents cruels de la police
des mœurs indifférents à mes pleurs
passer devant moi et même parfois
arborer un sourire de satisfaction aux
lèvres
depuis quelques minutes on attend de mon
sort des hurlements déchirants d'une
femme venant d'un des bureaux m'a glacé
le sang la peur m'a envahi
[Musique]
en voyant ma terreur l'un des agents me
dit elle reçoit des coups de fouet pour
avoir eu une relation illicite avec un
homme illégitime selon la charia
le lendemain j'ai été libéré après avoir
payé une amende astronomique et signer
un engagement de ne plus réitérer une
relation illégitime selon la charia mais
pendant très longtemps les hurlements
déchirants de cette femme m'ont fait
cauchemar des la nuit
durant les 43 dernières années des
millions d'iraniennes comme moi ont été
arrêtés et soumises à la sauvagerie et à
la cruauté du régime au nom de Dieu et
de l'Islam pour le seul crime d'être une
femme
jusqu'à mes 30 ans où j'ai quitté mon
pays j'ai été arrêté à Karach à 5
reprises par la police des mœurs pour
différents prétextes ils m'ont battu
m'ont menacé avec les pires insultes
pour que je ne porte pas plainte contre
leurs agissements sauvages et cruels en
me menaçant d'incubation pour trafic de
drogue
j'ai aussi été arrêté à trois reprises
pour mes activités pour la lutte et la
défense des droits humains et des
articles écrits dans des journaux
ma dernière inculpation a été selon eux
pour avoir mené des actions contre la
sécurité publique mais en réalité c'est
parce que j'ai aidé à la création d'une
campagne de défense des prisonniers
politiques et j'étais membre d'un
organisation de défense des droits
humains ça de Darus
j'ai passé 110 jours dans un cachot à
l'isolement à la section 209 de la
prison des vignes dans une cellule qui
faisait 2 mètres de long et 2 mètres de
large sa drosoft
minuit passées j'ai été interrogée sous
des tortures physiques et psychologiques
pour avouer et me dénoncer ainsi que mes
camarades
de ma cellule certaines nuits j'étais
interrogées durant 8 heures d'affilée de
telle sorte que je vomissais de manque
de sommeil et de pression psychologique
il m'insultait et m'accusé de relation
salle et malsaine avec les hommes
maintes fois ils ont jeté au sol la
chaise où j'étais assise pour me faire
peur et me choquer psychologiquement
après ma libération conditionnelle le
médecin m'a prescrit plus de 20 sortes
calmants par jour pour que je puisse
dormir un minimum
sous le jour du régime
moyenâgeux des mots là personne n'est à
l'abri d'être torturé enfermé tué arrêté
et menacé
ni les enfants ni les femmes ni les
artistes ni les écrivains
niorité religieuse ni les étudiants ni
les enseignants ni les avocats ni les
défenseurs des droits des ouvriers et
des instituteurs des instituteurs et ni
même les sportifs
durant les deux derniers mois les agents
des Gardiens de la Révolution avec une
cruauté sans nom ont tellement tapé avec
des matraques sur la tête des jeunes
femmes et hommes innocents tels que Marc
sort iPhone et hadith qu'ils ont sont
morts
ils ont jeté du haut d'un immeuble le
corps des jeunes filles et ont obligé
leur famille par leur torture
insoutenable de dire qu'elle s'était
suicidée
nous connaissons l'identité de ces
jeunes et de ses enfants là mais le
meurtre de centaines d'enfants et de
jeunes innocents par les démons de ce
régime n'est pas encore d'annoncées
en tant que femme et journaliste je vous
demande de faire tout ce que vous pouvez
pour éliminer cette barbarie et ce
terrorisme qui ont détruit la vie des
citoyens iraniens et même celle du
Moyen-Orient
je vous demande de placer les musiciens
des Gardiens de la révolution sur la
liste des terroristes de couper couper
toute relation économique avec ce régime
sanguinaire démola
dans liste de terroristiques
de placer tous les membres du
gouvernement les gouverneurs les
responsables régionaux les chefs de
toutes les forces miliciens et des
gardiens de leur de la révolution sur la
liste des terroristes et couper toute
relation
économique je déliran hors de la
Commission sur la condition de la femme
main dominante régime
le peuple iranien considère le régime
démolas comme leur plus grand et
dangereux ennemis et demande au monde
libre de défendre leur vie par tous les
moyens possibles face à cette ennemi
sanguinaire
sachez que le maintien de ce régime aura
pour conséquence non seulement le
massacre des Iraniens mais aussi il
mettra en danger la sécurité mondiale
avec le soutien du terrorisme dans cette
région
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame pour ce témoignage terrible
et qu'on imagine très douloureux ça se
passe chaque jour ça se passe tous les
jours en Iran merci aussi beaucoup
beaucoup pour votre courage depuis
toujours depuis l'âge de vos 15 ans
premier emprisonnement et merci encore
pour le courage que vous exprimez une
fois de plus ce soir devant tout le
monde merci beaucoup madame merci bonne
soirée
[Applaudissements]
nous accueillons
un nouveau témoin si vous voulez bien
pencher merci
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs tout
d'abord je vous excuse pour bien
il faut que je parle personne pour bien
exprimer mes sentiments pendant ce
témoignage je parle personne
personne
je suis ingénieur en
aménagement du territoire
j'ai 45 ans et depuis mon arrivée en
France il y a 12 ans je suis l'un des
fondateurs de l'association l'ami du
citoyen qui organise des formations au
droit civil
remercie de l'espace de parole que vous
me donnez aujourd'hui
à Island char dans une famille nombreuse
traditionnelle de 11 personnes
après la Révolution islamique en 79 de
de mes frères ont été arrêtés l'un après
l'autre à un an d'intervalle par les
agents du régime tous deux à seulement
15 ans ils ont été emprisonnés accusés
de diffusion de tracts anti-régime
islamiques
a été condamné à mort et l'autre à neuf
ans d'emprisonnement
pour que vous sachiez ce qui se passe en
Iran je vais témoigner de ce qui arrive
à nous et aux personnes qui sont
enfermées dans ces jours
au bout de la deuxième année de prison
de mon frère des représentants de
l'Assemblée nationale de la République
islamique ont rendu visite au
prisonniers et leur ont demandé
avez-vous été torturé
personne parmi les prisonniers n'osent
parler de la réalité des tortures
infligées en prison mais mon frère
s'élevé a dit depuis le 1er jour de
notre incarcération tous les jours une
torture et il a montré au représentants
les marques laissées par les coups de
fouet reçu et les contusions sur son
corps
après le départ de représentants les
responsables impitoyables de la prison
au mi mon frère dans un cachot à
l'isolement ils l'ont violé pour en
faire un exemple une leçon pour les
autres prisonniers mon frère était
encore mineur
mon frère en prison après ce viol il
s'est complètement effondré
psychologiquement
quand ma mère est allée en prison lui
rendre visite et qu'elle a appris ce
qu'il lui était arrivé elle s'est
précipitée en criant au bureau de
assadolor lodgevaldi le bourreau de la
prison des vignes pour protester
ils ont aussi arrêté ma mère qui avait
40 et quelques années à ce moment-là et
lui ont infligé de terribles tortures
sans que nous ayons aucune nouvelle
d'elle
après un mois ils l'ont ramené en
ambulance dans un sale état sur un
brancard en train de mourir et l'on
déposé à la maison où nous étions ses
enfants de bas âge
ma mère tremblait de tout son corps et
avait beaucoup de mal à respirer
nous les petits enfants on a pensé
qu'elle allait mourir ou l'homme
allongé face à la Mecque respectant les
rituels religieux
pour qu'elle termine sa vie moins
douloureusement
après quelques mois ma mère peu à peu
aller mieux physiquement mais
terriblement fragilisé mentalement et
psychologiquement
pour se venger à chaque fois qu'elle
allait au mosquée ou elle a prière du
vendredi
elle a arraché les photos de Romains
révolution et toute seule scander
des slogans contre
elle a été arrêtée et enfermée à
plusieurs reprises
on a tué mon frère en prison en 1992
encore aujourd'hui on ignore ce qu'il
s'est passé dans la prison et comment il
a été tué
la dernière fois que ma mère a été
arrêtée et en prison à Rome elle a
attrapé la tuberculose à cause de
l'hygiène détaillance de la prison
elle a été privée de soins et les décédé
à 54 ans d'une infection pulmonaire
qui n'avaient aucune activité politique
Stéphane
activité politique ont été également
emprisonnés et subit d'atroces torture
pour nous faire peur
j'ai été aussi emprisonnée torturé deux
fois en Iran pour avoir tenu un blog
internet et avoir défendu des
prisonniers politiques
le reste des membres de ma famille qui
n'ont aucune activité politique sont
encore en Iran et sont toujours sous
pression et harcelées
ce n'est pas seulement notre famille qui
a subi ce genre d'horrible harcèlement
et de torture des milliers de familles
iraniennes ont subi et subissent
toujours cela et de manière même encore
pire et plus terrifiant
aujourd'hui que je me trouve ici avec
vous c'est même chose terrifiantes
arrivent aux familles de ceux qui sont
arrêtés lors des protestations de la
Révolution
beaucoup de vie sont prises et beaucoup
de familles sacrifiées par injustice
[Musique]
actuellement la République islamique a
arrêté plus de 15000 manifestants et
tuer des centaines de personnes
chaque individu arrêté chacune des
familles des tués ont une histoire
semblable
et dans mes motards
vous avez probablement vu et entendu que
la majorité des députés iraniens a
demandé l'exécution des manifestants et
ramener lui-même tel un assassin cruel
décide du devenir des êtres humains
innocents
cher député ma question est combien
d'individus on ira doit être tué torturé
et disparaître
pour que vous et la société mondiale
premier une décision ferme face à ce
régime terrifiant
nous avons besoin de votre aide pour
être libéré de cette république
islamique sanguinaire avec moins de vie
sacrifiées moins de 100 versées
nous demandons une aide humaniste active
pour les projetiers
nous souhaitons que le lourd dossier de
la République islamique soit saisi par
le Conseil de la sécurité et que les
pays
occidentaux prennent la décision ferme
de ne plus reconnaître le régime de la
République islamique comme légitime
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
j'ajoute rien parce que je crois que ça
pourrait être indécent et le mieux c'est
qu'on ne vous écoute madame
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs
une femme qui n'a jamais accepté le port
du voile obligatoire et c'est pour ça
que les agents de la République
islamique mon frappé et blessé à la tête
j'aurais pu mourir comme la jeune femme
de 22 ans mars à mini qui a été arrêté
battue et tué parce qu'à leurs yeux
elles ne portaient pas correctement son
voile
oui j'aurais pu aussi mourir mais je
survécu j'ai pris ma fille par la main
et j'ai fui avec elle seule j'ai fui mon
pays pour rester vivante
je me suis réfugiée ici dans votre pays
en France le pays de la liberté
d'expression et des droits humains pour
rester vivante et pour pouvoir être la
voix de mes camarades la voix des amis
qui ont été exécutés
je vais vous raconter un de mes premiers
souvenirs j'avais 5 ans quand les
Gardiens de la Révolution ont arrêté mon
père
mon père était bel homme un grimpeur
émérite bien bâti avec une moustache
bien fournie noire mon père était mon
héros
ils ont ramené mon père à notre petit
chez nous pour fouiller et saisir des
documents contre le régime
mon père avait les mains menotté par
derrière sa chemise blanche était tachée
de sang je voyais les pieds de mon héros
tremblait
mon père a voulu me caresser les cheveux
mais ses mains étaient menottées ils ont
ramené mon père avec eux ils ont ramené
mon héros avec eux
accusé d'avoir écrit un poème contre le
régime j'avais 22 ans quand on m'a
arrêté pour mon interview télé à Voice
of America Neuvy
mais avec toutes mes œuvres interdites
de parution en Iran une autrice avec des
collègues auteurs qui se font exécuter
en Iran
je ne suis pas venue ici seulement pour
parler de ma vie je suis ici pour
témoigner du meurtre de la vie en Iran
ium
depuis la Révolution islamique dans mon
pays il tue la vie l'amour le chant et
la joie dans mon pays même s'embrasser
est un interdit
couche de chaude Nico
j'ai plein de voix qui résonnent dans ma
tête la voix de Nico tu es à 16 ans elle
voulait devenir chanteuse
la voix de sorino tu es à 17 ans elle
aimait les mathématiques
la voix de David 27 ans exécuté David
s'est battu jusqu'à la dernière minute
pour retrouver sa liberté
[Musique]
la voix de Back toche poète est l'un de
mes proches amis
back toche n'était pas peureux comme moi
back toche ne s'est pas enfui
il est resté et il est mort en prison
dans la voix des femmes emprisonnée qui
se font torturer et qui hurle de douleur
c'est
Michaud la voix des jolies filles qui se
font violer en prison
en réalité je n'ai pas le courage ni la
force de vous dire ce qu'ils font aux
femmes dans les prisons de la République
islamique ni comment il les viole
imaginez la pire version
occupée par l'ennemi et que vous êtes
obligé de vous enfuir de quitter votre
pays
imaginez qu'on vous a invité au Sénat de
ce pays et on vous demande d'être la
voix de vos compatriotes durant 5
minutes
durant ces 5 minutes je pourrais être la
voix de qui de quelle peine quelle
douleur
mesdames messieurs dans mon pays ça fait
43 ans que le peuple se bat il se bat
pour des valeurs pour lesquelles la
France s'est battue
j'aimerais que vous sachiez que votre
vote sera très important pour sauver des
vies l'autre femme
au moment de voter je vous prie de
penser aux femmes aux enfants aux jeunes
Iraniens aux jeunes qui sont tués et
exécutés chaque jour en Iran
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en Iran
n'arrive même pas en temps de guerre
dans les autres pays
l'arrestation des collégiens et lycéens
chez lycam mostarim
l'utilisation des ambulances pour
conduire des agents de la répression
et des dizaines d'autres agissements qui
sont interdits même en temps de guerre
[Musique]
réfugiée dans votre pays je vous demande
de l'aide le régime de la République
islamique est un régime terroriste ne
négociez pas avec ce régime reconnaissez
officiellement la révolution du peuple
iranien mon hardering
nous avons le droit de vivre en liberté
égalité fraternité en votant contre la
République islamique vous pouvez sauver
la vie de tous ceux qui sont en train de
se battre pour la liberté
soutenez le peuple iranien l'histoire ne
s'écrit pas par les dictateurs elle
s'écrit par le peuple et le peuple
iranien vous demande votre soutien et
votre aide
soyez notre voix femme vie liberté
[Applaudissements]
nous accueillons monsieur hirbotte
dégagniazar qui est avocat
qui est avocat en droit international
c'est lui qui entre autres a coordonner
le soutien à Nasrine sautoudet ça
concerne iranienne défenseur des droits
de l'homme qui a toujours été persécuté
par le régime et puis nous accueillons
aussi son confrères en même temps
monsieur Richard Sédillot qui lui aussi
est avocat en droit international et
spécialisé sur la question des droits de
l'homme merci
bonsoir et merci de cette invitation
c'est très difficile de prendre la
parole maintenant
déjà sur les pour les qualités je rends
à César ce qui appartient à César le
spécialiste du droit international et de
l'autre côté de la barre
je ne je n'ai fait que qu'assister et je
vais vous expliquer un peu ce que
j'essaye de à mon petit niveau de faire
pour
de faire pour me rendre utile alors on
m'a dit des très bref
je sais je sais pas faire plus ah j'ai
oublié le petit pour le
qui est sur la table
je vais essayer alors je vais préparer
une intervention assez
dans un temps peut-être un peu plus
structuré je vais essayer de vous donner
des marqueurs pour faire bref et donc je
suis je vous prie d'excuser ce propos
s'il est un peu déstructuré mais je vais
essayer d'aller à l'essentiel pour
pouvoir laisser le temps à la salle
après de poser des questions déjà un
marqueur personnel je suis arrivé en
France à l'âge de 10 ans en 1981
et je ne peux pas ne pas profiter de
cette
de cette salle et de cette audience dans
cette maison pour ne pas remercier ce
pays d'accueil qui m'a permis d'avoir
une vie sereine j'étais venu passer
quelques semaines de vacances en
attendant que mon père qui nous avait
accompagné à la frontière participe à un
renversement
ça fait maintenant depuis 1980 je suis
là et il n'est jamais venu nous
rejoindre donc
ça c'est le marqueur personnel je suis
avocat à Paris je
suis ancien membre du conseil de l'ordre
et membre actuellement du Conseil
national des barreaux et à ce titre
depuis mon implication à l'ordre
peut-être un peu avant du fait peut-être
de ma spécialité du mois de la
spécificité de ma langue
j'ai gardé un contact avec les confrères
iraniens et notamment au moment du
du drame qui a vécu notre confrère
nassrine setudet
à différents niveaux à l'époque Richard
était au CNB moi j'étais au barreau de
Paris on s'est coordonné et on s'est
fait ce qu'on s'est mieux faire les
avocats ça veut dire les portes paroles
et on a essayé de garder le message et
d'avoir une information c'est un peu ce
qu'on essaie de faire aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir garder ce lien avec les
confrères un slogan que je pense réel
les oublier c'est les condamner
donc un deuxième marqueur à ce titre
d'ailleurs je vais vous lire tout de
suite un message que Nasrine très court
message que notre frère mastering
surtout les qui ne pouvait être présente
avec nous alors elle est condamnée mais
un signal de à domicile et l'aurait bien
souhaité mais c'est assez aléatoire
internet pour avoir des contacts et
pouvoir organiser
elle nous écrit et donc c'est une
traduction libre pour vous je suis
profondément reconnaissant aux
consciences éveillées qui ont déclarant
leur solidarité avec le soulèvement
femme vie liberté font entendre nos voix
en Iran et permettre au peuple iranien
d'espérer pouvoir profiter un jour des
avantages de la démocratie
l'histoire n'oubliera jamais un tel
soutien Nasri
un deuxième marqueur plus personnel que
je vous donne pour comprendre peut-être
la spécificité de l'Iran et le caractère
résilient des Iraniens et pour vous
montrer que 6 ans sont là aujourd'hui
c'est que la résistance
dure depuis un certain nombre d'années
en réalité
vous savez Richard boa peut-être vous en
parler
il a fait un petit film il a participé
avec un collectif où on voyait des
actrices se couper les cheveux c'est un
sens symbolique pour nous ce symbole il
nous vient du champ nommé le livre de
fèves aussi qui a été créé dans les
heures dans l'an 1000 c'est-à-dire pour
400 ans après avoir été où l'islam s'est
installé pour créer une résistance une
spécificité c'est pour ça que les fêtes
iraniennes fêtes païenne existe toujours
les faits anciennes existent toujours et
ce Guy souborum c'est-à-dire ce fait de
se couper les cheveux symboliquement
qu'on voit il faut que vous compreniez
la symbolique c'est le rituel
de la mort de farangers
je suis toujours entre les deux langues
c'est un peu pharyngis sont allés
c'est le problème des GDJ et des J on
m'a collé moi 2h mon prénom à mon nom de
famille que je n'avais pas donc des
pharyngis dans le champ nommé donc c'est
important ce symbole est important c'est
pas simplement de se couper les cheveux
c'est que ça nous renvoie à notre
histoire ancestrale et à notre culture
qui est une culture autonome de
résistance et de résilience
un deuxième message pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui
ici on s'organise on est plein de
collectifs moi j'ai la chance au niveau
je suis de d'être membre du Conseil
national des barreaux et de participer
donc à faire voter des résolutions pour
la défense des confrères je vais rester
sur ce domaine de des droits de l'homme
des droits des avocats des droits à une
justice équitable des droits une vraie
justice de la Défense et de des gens des
manifestants et de l'arrêt des
condamnations à mort qui sont devenus
une arme de
une arme réellement de répression de
manifestants j'avais un beau
développement sur le sujet je vais vous
les je vais pas vous le donner je vais
tout simplement ce que je n'ai pas le
temps par contre je vais vous montrer ce
qu'on fait on est à plusieurs collectifs
à travailler ensemble ce travail a été
fait par un collectif d'artistes dont
l'un des membres
s'épandre qui est venu au Conseil
national des barreaux pour remercier la
profession d'avocat pour tout ce que
nous faisons pour soutenir les confrères
faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui on Iran quand
vous êtes avocat et vous allez défendre
quelqu'un vous êtes assimilé à celui que
vous défendez et donc vous vous
retrouvez vous même en prison pour les
peines les plus graves c'est l'article
jeu de souvenirs
43 de la constitution du code pénal qui
dit que à partir du moment où vous êtes
sur les crimes les plus graves vous
n'avez pas le droit de choisir librement
vos avocats vous êtes obligé de choisir
sur une liste d'avocats
quand on sait le contexte général ou la
pendaison a été appelée de ses vœux par
un nombre important de personnes
à l'Assemblée au parlement iranien alors
la grande majorité je crois que c'est
277 qui ont voté ça bah vous imaginez
dans quelle situation se retrouve les
gens et pourquoi tout le monde va dans
la rue alors
je sais pas voilà ce genre de choses que
nous faisons celui-ci est beaucoup plus
visuel que un autre travail que nous
faisons dans un autre collectif avec
Richard il vous en parlera plus
ce genre de choses c'est de répertorier
jour le jour alors on n'est pas les
seuls à le faire et c'est important de
que vous le sachiez de remonter il y a
par exemple aussi sur papier cet ouvrage
qui est fait au jour le jour chaque jour
on voit grâce aux réseaux sociaux ce qui
se passe et
on fait des témoignages on écrit on
écrit les lieux on écrit les noms les
noms on écrit les causes et on envisage
et on espère on compte beaucoup sur
cette future résolution pour nous donner
les moyens de pouvoir de rendre justice
à toutes ces personnes là vous avez 60
enfants
d'âge différents qui ont tous soit été
abattus par balle soit son décédé suite
au coût qu'ils ont reçu et qui n'avait
rien demandé d'autre que pouvoir vivre
librement et peut-être pour certains
même traverser la rue
je pense que ça va être beaucoup plus
parlant que de vous faire mon
développement sur ce que nous faisons et
sincèrement aujourd'hui
le message que je vais vous faire passer
c'est n'hésitez pas à liker n'hésitez
pas à montrer que vous êtes là derrière
vos ordinateurs derrière vos téléphones
parce que de l'autre côté ils le savent
et ça leur donne de l'énergie
je vais laisser et pas aller beaucoup
plus longtemps je vais laisser Richard
peut-être terminer sur les actions
concrètes qu'on essaie de mener parce
qu'on est là pour tenter de ça mais
sachez que il y aura un alors révolution
j'ai deux questions alors je vais y
répondre tout de suite
on va les y poser des questions non
allez-y
non mais c'est bien de la poser parce
que je me rappelle plus
vous vous rappelez pas des questions
donc moi non plus si la première est-ce
qu'on peut encore dialoguer avec l'Iran
et si oui comment alors j'aime beaucoup
cette question c'est pour ça que je
voulais vous me la poser parce que vous
me posez la question de dialoguer avec
l'Iran et pas avec les Iraniens
ça dépend de la définition qu'on donne à
l'Iran on peut dire le gars avec l'Iran
parce que c'est un pays complexe avec
des populations avec des des
cultures complexes et il ne faut surtout
pas hésiter à travers les réseaux
sociaux quand vous avez des doutes quand
vous avez besoin de parler avec
quelqu'un quand vous vous étonnez quand
vous voulez faire partie de faire part
de votre solidarité quand vous lisez
quelque chose vous avez des petites
choses comme google trad vous écrivez en
français vous écrirez en perçant un peu
mauvais mais ça leur fera plaisir donc
dialoguer avec les Iraniens dialoguer
avec les gens que vous avez de l'autre
côté qu'il ne reste pas anonyme et que
vous ne restez pas anonyme pour eux
c'est déjà le premier point
et alors la deuxième question évidemment
donc on a compris qu'il fallait se
mobiliser sur les réseaux sociaux
exprimer notre solidarité mais plus
concrètement qu'est-ce que la communauté
internationale est plus particulièrement
les instances politiques françaises et
notamment les parlementaires peuvent
faire pour aider les Iraniens
j'aurais aimé que ce soit l'Iran aussi
cette fois-ci
ce qui peut faire c'est de ce qu'on est
en train de faire ce soir parler de nous
faire écho de ce qu'ils font recueillir
les preuves
faire tout ce qui est prévu tout ce qui
a été dit depuis le début c'est-à-dire
sanctionner les coupables dire qu'il y a
une justice après qui a un lendemain
avec une justice donner des horizons aux
gens qui sont là-bas et pourquoi pas moi
je suis dans l'utopie je sais qu'il y
aura des difficultés mais je rêverais
une saisine de la Cour pénale
internationale par la France qui aurait
saisi le Conseil de sécurité pour
pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre des des réels
des réelles sanctions maintenant j'ai
une casquette qui est peut-être une
casquette un peu différente dans ma
pratique quotidienne j'ai une casquette
de médiateur je fais beaucoup ça je suis
désolé que la France ait décidé au mois
d'octobre dernier fin de 6 octobre
dernier d'envoyer un ambassadeur en
France alors que tout le monde
faisait partir les ambassadeurs mais
chiche maintenant cogner qu'ils servent
qu'il servent réellement à la diplomatie
et qu'il soit l'acteur d'un dialogue et
que le porte-parole de la France est des
libertés et qui soit un peu courageux
sur ce point-là
j'avais prévu un extrait de du
Dictionnaire de Diderot et d'Alembert de
1751 qui donne la définition
historique de ce que doit être la
médiation en France et qui était la
leçon de l'école de de la diplomatie
française qui a été un peu oubliée je
vous lirai pas parce que c'est un peu
long mais je vous invite à aller le voir
c'est très intéressant et c'est parlant
et chiche puisque vous avez envoyé un
émissaire et que aujourd'hui c'est un
diplomate français qui a qui vient de
prendre fausse qu'il est le courage de
porter une voie courageuse et de
demander à ce que cela cesse et
participer comme ça a été fait dans
d'autres pays peut-être sous l'égide de
la France à un dialogue et pouvoir
peut-être faire sortir toutes ces toutes
ces personnes qui sont dans Heavy et qui
sont des activistes qui sont en prison
mais qui ont aussi une voix qui ont
aussi des choses à dire
merci j'ai fait le plus rapidement
possible
[Applaudissements]
et bien je vais également essayer d'être
rapide et de structurer ma pensée même
si devant le raccourcir je vais
probablement échapper à ce que j'avais
imaginé vous dire complètement
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
question iranienne alors que je n'ai pas
la chance d'être iranien lorsque j'ai
entendu parler du sort qui était réservé
à notre conserve Nasrine surtout des
alors que j'étais membre du Conseil
National des Barreaux condamné en tout à
38 années de prison et 148 coups de
fouet
le barreau français sachez-le est très
attaché à la défense de ses confrères
qui à travers le monde ou que ce soit
sont menacés et je crois pouvoir dire
que c'est probablement l'un des barreaux
ou le barreau au monde qui envoie le
plus souvent des observateurs pour
assister à des procès ou pour venir en
aide sur nos confrères qui sont menacés
je pars en quelques jours au Gabon pour
défendre un confrère ça n'a pas de lien
avec l'Iran mais qui est lui-même menacé
en d'autres circonstances
c'est pour nous une tâche essentielle
j'avais donc proposé que le portrait de
Nasrine soit apposé sur la façade du
Conseil National des Barreaux boulevard
Haussmann un grand immeuble et
l'assemblée générale du Conseil avait
voté cette idée et j'ai été heureux
évidemment que la présidence décide de
couvrir l'entièreté de cette immeuble
avec ce portrait ce qui a eu je crois un
effet considérable et qui a pu être de
nature aussi à la protéger irbod le
disait à l'instant très bien il l'a fait
lui-même pour le barreau de Paris à
l'époque et
la notoriété nous le savons fort
heureusement peut participer à la
protection de ceux que nous souhaitons
défendre et c'était la raison de ce
mouvement et puis nous avions déposé
également à recours devant une instance
des Nations Unies mais il est évident
que que son sort était déjà extrêmement
connu alors aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut faire juridiquement la
situation est difficile pourquoi parce
que vous le savez
l'Iran est une véritable dictature de
sorte qu'elle ne ratifie pas les
instruments internationaux qui
pourraient éventuellement permettre de
mettre en œuvre des procédures destinées
à protéger les victimes
l'Iran à ratifier ce qu'on appelle le
pack international relatif aux droits
civil et politique qui est un instrument
très important mais n'a pas ratifié le
Protocole facultatif qui nous
permettrait de saisir le comité des
droits de l'homme de l'ONU de requête
individuelle
si regrettable mais c'est évidemment
volontaire de la part de cet état comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer
nous pouvons saisir le groupe de travail
et la science Unies sur la détention
arbitraire qui lui reste compétent mais
qui rendra un avis probablement très
intelligent comme il le fait
habituellement
mais qui évidemment ne sera pas
contraignant comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
le droit français ne permet pas d'agir
devant les juridictions françaises sur
le fondement du crime de génocide ou
même du crime contre l'humanité commis
commis en Iran
alors nous avons imaginé éventuellement
que nous pourrions peut-être déposer les
plaintes sur le fondement de la
Convention contre la torture je vais pas
vous faire un cours de droit mais
l'avantage de cette convention c'est
qu'elle porte une véritable compétence
universelle ce qui veut dire que les
juridictions françaises ou anglaises ou
belges ou italiennes sont compétentes
pour connaître des crimes de torture
quel que soit la nationalité de l'auteur
quel que soit la nationalité de la
victime et quel que soit le territoire
du pays sur lequel le crime a été commis
alors cette année normalement
la seule condition c'est que le
tortionnaire se trouve sur le territoire
ou la plainte a été déposée
au moment de son arrestation c'est avec
la France si une plainte est déposée en
France la France n'aurait pas le droit
d'aller le chercher dans un pays tiers
d'accord et la France ne pourrait pas
non plus demander son extradition mais
en revanche nous nous sommes dit mais
pourquoi ne pas inviter et je
souhaiterais que le Sénat travaille sur
cette question qui a les moyens que nous
n'avons pas forcément pourquoi ne pas
faire en sorte que dans tous les pays au
moins européens soit déposer les
plaintes contre ces tortionnaires pour
les empêcher
définitivement de voyager dans quelques
pays démocratiques que ce soit et nous
avons déjà des renseignements et nous
avons déjà grâce au travail absolument
cas qui a été fait
nous avons déjà des noms des noms de
victimes mais également des nombres
criminels je peux vous assurer que ça
aurait un impact immédiatique et
juridique considérable alors on en a
parlé parce que a eu lieu il y a il y a
peu de temps le Congrès mondial contre
la peine de mort à Berlin et nous avons
évidemment beaucoup parlé de l'Iran
ce que la peine de mort à laquelle nous
sommes évidemment tous profondément
opposés
a toujours été appliquée scandaleusement
en Iran à l'encontre des majeurs des
femmes et même des enfants
et nous savons très bien aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle est une arme politique
contre les mains des mollas nous avons
très bien que de très nombreuses
personnes arrêtées de façon complètement
arbitraire vont être condamnés à mort et
probablement exécuté
c'est la raison pour laquelle le Congrès
s'étamparé et l'association Ensemble
contre la peine de mort qui
organise ce congrès fait partie d'une
plateforme qui s'appelle impact Iran et
elle travaille considérablement sur ces
questions qui réunit de nombreuses ONG
iraniennes qui je pense travailleront
aussi sur ces questions de torture et
j'espère que nous pourrons avancer je
peux vous annoncer aussi que nous avons
rédigé un mémoire un recours qui va être
signé par de nombreuses institutions
d'avocats le Conseil National des
Barreaux le barreau de Paris la
Fédération nationale des unions de
jeunes avocats le Syndicat des Avocats
de France
l'association des conseils d'entreprises
et la Conférence des Bâtonniers et
l'Observatoire International des avocats
en danger en centre contre la peine de
mort ces associations vont signer ce
recours qui va être déposé devant le
Rapporteur spécial sur l'indépendance
des juges et des avocats
vous allez me dire pourquoi les juges et
les avocats et pourquoi pas les autres
alors les rapporteurs spéciaux ont déjà
été très très alimentés d'information
parce que nous sommes avocats et que
nous avons souhaité saisir ce rapporteur
auquel peut-être pour l'instant beaucoup
d'ONG avaient moins pensé et c'est
normal
parce qu'un nouveau rapporteur a été
désigné et est entré en fonction
et parce que le sort qui est réservé ses
avocats absolument épouvantable pour
deux raisons je me déteste je vous
promets je me déteste pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que eux-mêmes à titre
individuel sont arrêtés torturés violées
en prison comme tous ceux qui le sont
mais on les arrête aussi pour ne pas
leur permettre de défendre ceux qui ont
été arrêtés et notamment ceux qui ont
été condamnés à mort et ne pas leur
permettre d'exercer le recours l'appel
qui doit être en principe formé dans les
20 jours de la condamnation je dis un
mot enfin sur la résolution des Nations
Unies qui doit être présenté jeudi aux
Nations Unies qui appellent qui décide
notamment d'une enquête internationale
il faut absolument que cette résolution
soit soutenue notamment par les
parlementaires français excusez-moi
non vous avez été court et en étant
court vous avez répondu à toutes mes
questions ce qui nous permet de
rattraper un petit peu la pendule et
peut-être on va on va pouvoir écouter
le prochain témoignage qui va être très
impressionnant puisqu'il s'agit du
témoignage de sherine ebadie que vous
connaissez évidemment tous qui est elle
aussi avocate et qui a été prix Nobel de
la paix
et c'est en visioconférence pardon
oui est-ce que vous nous entendez
bonsoir madame
alors on ne vous entend pas
[Musique]
assassiné par la force par les forces de
police
ce qui a déclenché les
restants protestations à ce jour aucune
suite n'a été donné à cette plainte
or deux journalistes qui ont pris une
photo de cette jeune femme
à l'hôpital
et qui ont publié un reportage sur son
enterrement dans la presse iranienne
emprisonné depuis plus de deux mois
accusés
laisse le meurtre un puni
et considère le journaliste comme un
délai répressible
dans ce pays
lors des 43 dernières années
un grand nombre de citoyens
ont payé de leur vie leur opposition au
régime en classe
le nombre de victimes
lors des protestations récentes n'est
pas clair
car l'État ne publie aucun chiffre
grâce aux informations délivrées par les
familles
et après vérification
par des organisations des droits de
l'homme
que des chiffres minimaux peuvent être
un
lors des récents d'affrontements au
moins
460 personnes
ont été tués par le régime à ce jour
parmi lesquels il y a au moins
enfants mineurs
c'est ce qui a incité l'UNICEF
à faire part de son indignation face à
cette violence
le nom précis des arrestations n'est pas
plus certain
mais je peux affirmer de façon certaine
que plus de 17000 personnes ont été
arrêtées lors de ces protestations
d'après une publication officielle de la
justice iranienne à ce jour 10
condamnations à mort ont été prononcées
dont l'une
à l'encontre d'un chanteur de rap
la violence de l'État s'est étendue même
aux hôpitaux
des patients blessés lors des
manifestations
sont
identifiés et arrêtés par la police
en cas de résistance de la part des
membres du personnel hospitalier eux
aussi font l'objet d'arrestation
il y a même eu un cas
où
des gaz lacrymogènes ont été diffusés au
sein de l'hôpital
la liberté d'expression
est bafoué à tel point en Iran
que lors des dernières protestations 17
avocats
se sont vues arrêtés simplement pour
avoir défendu leurs clients
certains d'entre eux ont pu être libérés
contre des cautions importants et
attendre d'être jugé
et d'autres sont encore en prison
de même des dizaines d'écrivains et de
journalistes sont arrêtés
ils sont en prison simplement pour cette
exprimer et avoir fait des révélations
sur des sujets dans le gouvernement ne
souhaitent pas entendre parler
les efforts entrepris par le peuple
iranien lors des dernières années pour
des réformes et pour une amélioration de
la situation ont été vains
aujourd'hui
le peuple se soulève depuis le mois de
septembre
pour changer ce régime
la devise de ce soulèvement et femme
liberté
ce slogan à deux versants
d'une part il rejette la théocratie
mais d'autre part
c'est qu'il exprime clairement de façon
positive une inspiration un régime
démocratique et laïque
conditions sine qua non de son
accomplissement
les pays européens
notamment le gouvernement français
peuvent être rassurés que l'avènement
d'un tel régiment en Iran
engendrerait une baisse considérable des
tensions dans la région
c'est quand une baisse de demande
d'asile
en raison d'une sérénité dans cette
région la violation des droits de
l'homme
et ses clientes en Iran que le Conseil
des droits de l'homme de l'ONU
a voté
le 24 novembre
par une nette majorité
la création d'une mission spéciale pour
enquêter sur la répression meurtrière de
ces protestations
hier
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
déclaré
qu'il ne collaborerait pas avec ladite
commission
ce qui est nullement une surprise
dans la mesure où cela fait 11 ans
que les
n'accordent pas de visa au rapporteur
spécial de l'ONU sur les droits de
l'homme
tout ce que je viens de dire
ne donne qu'un aperçu de la situation
actuelle en république islamique
dans ce contexte le peuple iranien
demande à l'état français
de ne pas soutenir le régime de la
République islamique
c'est qu'en réaction à la répression
sanglante
qu'il renvoie l'ambassadeur d'Iran
et que les relations politiques entre
les deux pays se limitent
à des rapports consulaires
aussi
nous demandons
pour représentant du peuple français
de reconnaître le corps des Gardiens de
la Révolution comme terroriste et de
prendre des sanctions contre lui je
rappelle
que d'après la Constitution
le rôle de ce corps est exclusivement de
protéger le système de la République
islamique il n'a pas de lien avec
l'armée régulière qui assure la défense
des frontières
de nombreux jeunes ont perdu la vie pour
la liberté et la démocratie en Iran
ne permettait pas
que le peuple iranien soit encore plus
ennuyé
nous vous serons reconnaissants
de vous placer du bon côté de l'histoire
je mets fin
à ma prise de parole en vous remerciant
à nouveau
et je suis disposée à répondre à toutes
questions
merci merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame d'avoir pris le temps de ce
témoignage
pour je crois qu'on court toujours un
petit peu après le temps donc pour
conclure en tout cas les questions je
crois qu'il y en a eu moi qui me qui me
tarde depuis le début on parle beaucoup
de répression on parle beaucoup de morts
on parle beaucoup de tortures de quoi
parle-t-on exactement de crime contre
l'humanité
oui alors je devais pas
vous faire un cours je vous rassure sur
le crime contre l'humanité et sa
définition ce sera un petit peu long
il ne fait pas l'ombre d'un doute
aujourd'hui que l'ampleur des crimes
commis à l'égard de la population
cette ampleur est constitutive d'un
crime contre l'humanité
le crime de génocide pourra
éventuellement être discuté notamment à
l'encontre de la population du Kurdistan
et du balouchkistan il n'est pas
impossible à mon sens lorsque des
informations complémentaires nous aurons
été données que l'on puisse considérer
qu'un crime de génocide avec une
attention de destruction d'une partie de
la population
était constituée on l'État et en
revanche à mon sens il ne fait
strictement aucun doute sur l'existence
d'un crime contre l'humanité au sens
notamment du traité de Rome porte en
création de la Cour pénale
internationale même si celle-ci ne
pourra malheureusement être saisie que
par le Conseil de sécurité puisque
l'Iran n'a pas ratifié ce traité
merci Maître
je crois madame que la conclusion vous
appartient madame indique Lyon vous êtes
présidente de la délégation au droit des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les femmes
merci beaucoup
votre magister Votre Altesse Royale
chers collègues sénatrice et sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je veux commencer
par remercier l'ensemble des
intervenants qui se sont exprimés avec
courage ce soir au Sénat c'est un
véritable honneur pour moi de conclure
cette conférence que le président Bruno
Retailleau et moi-même avons souhaité
dédié au courage du peuple iranien et
plus précisément à celui des femmes de
ce pays qui au péril de leur vie se
battent chaque jour depuis plus de deux
mois contre le régime
permettez-moi de remercier tout
particulièrement Bruno retaillod qui est
à l'initiative de cet événement nous
formons une équipe dans le département
de la Vendée je connais la force de son
engagement la sincérité avec laquelle il
le porte et la solidité de ses
convictions qui ne sont jamais à
géométrie variable vous comptez vous
pouvez compter sur lui vous pouvez
compter sur nous comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire nous
parlementaires français affirmant que
les femmes iraniennes ne sont pas seules
et que nous les soutenons dans leur
combat héro et héroïque elles ne sont
pas seules d'abord parce qu'elles sont
soutenues par le peuple iranien un vent
de liberté historique souffle
aujourd'hui sur l'Iran hommes et femmes
réunis pour défendre leur liberté
fondamentale et leurs droits depuis la
mort athéhéran de Macha Amini le 16
septembre 2022 trois jours après son
arrestation par la police desmeurs
iranienne pour une simple mèche de
cheveux qui dépassait de son voile des
milliers de manifestants et manifestants
iraniens risquent chaque jour leur vie
pour défier le pouvoir en place et
défendre leur liberté en premier lieu
celle des femmes au péril de leur ville
les Iraniennes arrachent et brûlent
publiquement leur voile symboles
d'oppression par le régiment place je
salue la dignité la force le courage de
ces femmes que rien ne semble pouvoir
arrêter comme vous madame monsieur qui
avait témoigné tout à l'heure la
contestation populaire c'est aujourd'hui
transformée en un mouvement
révolutionnaire dirigé contre la
théocratie au pouvoir en Iran c'est
toute la jeunesse iranienne qui défie le
pouvoir des bols là la jeune génération
ne se bat pas pour une idéologie mais
tout simplement pour la liberté et pour
la vie
les manifestations et émeutes qui ne
cessent de prendre de l'ampleur dans le
pays depuis plus de deux mois on fait
des centaines de morts et entraîner des
milliers d'arrestations arbitraire vos
témoignages ce soir confirment la
violence et la répression par le pouvoir
en place nous les avons entendu et
écoutez il nous oblige chez témoignages
le régime faire régner la peur des mises
à mort la torture les passages à tabac
les tirs à balles réelles sur des
manifestants non armés en pleine rue le
régime tue la police iranienne n'hésite
plus à entrer dans les unes universités
pour réprimer les étudiants soupçonnés
d'apporter leur soutien à la lutte pour
les droits des femmes ces universités où
les filles sont aujourd'hui plus
nombreuses que les garçons
plus nombreuses oui pourtant les femmes
et les filles en Iran sont toujours
considérés comme des citoyennes de
seconde zone par le pouvoir en place
leur persécution perdurent ainsi depuis
de nombreuses années les discriminations
et les humiliations envers les femmes
sont nombreuses les droits des femmes et
des filles sont continuellement bafoués
la loi et les pratiques de la police des
mœurs en atteste pour mémoire l'âge
légal du mariage pour les filles est
toujours fixées à 13 ans les pères
peuvent même obtenir des autorisations
pour marier leurs filles à un âge encore
plus jeune le port du voile imposé par
la loi est synonyme de harcèlement
quotidien
d'invibilisation des femmes de tests
et d'actes de torture de la part des
Gardiens de la Révolution la
discrimination se retrouve dans le droit
pénal puisqu'en Iran les filles peuvent
être condamnées à mort dès l'âge de 9
ans contre 15 pour les garçons
désormais la contestation gagne tout le
pays il ne s'agit plus seulement de
dénoncer les atteintes aux droits des
femmes c'est tout un régime et ses abus
qui sont remis en cause ce soir je veux
témoigner de mon admiration de notre
admiration de devant le courage de ce
peuple qui se soulève ces femmes et ses
hommes exemplaires préfèrent mourir
plutôt que de vivre dans un pays où
leurs droits fondamentaux sont niés si
les femmes iraniennes ne sont pas seules
c'est aussi parce que des voix s'élèvent
dans le monde entier pour les soutenir
comme nous tous si c'est ce soir vous
tous et toutes mesdames et messieurs
mais aussi les sénatrices et sénateurs
qui sont là dans la salle et qui
relayent d'ores et déjà depuis un
certain temps tous ces messages que vous
avez exprimés ce soir pendant cette
conférence je vois au premier rang
Nathalie Goulet Marie Mercier j'ai vu
tout à l'heure Joël gariomella Valérie
Boyer et d'autres elle se Joseph voilà
vous laissez natrices et les sénateurs
sont à vos
la délégation au droit des femmes que je
préside et le Sénat tout entier sont aux
côtés du peuple iranien si le mouvement
de contestation était à l'origine un
mouvement féministe tourné vers la
défense des droits des femmes iraniennes
il sait très vite transformé en un
profond mouvement de contestation du
régime autoritaire iranien pourquoi
parce que lorsque les droits des femmes
sont bafouées c'est la société tout
entière qui est bafouée ce sont les
droits humains qui sont niés défendre
les libertés et droits fondamentaux des
femmes ça se battre pour une société
égalitaire et respectueuse des
différences la force de la révolution
populaire qui s'est mise en marche ne va
pas et ne doit pas s'arrêter elle
débouchera je l'espère sur la
construction d'une société iranienne
plus juste dont les principaux piliers
seront la liberté et la la
la communauté internationale si elle est
vraiment attachée à la défense des
droits des femmes et des droits humains
doit envoyer un signal fort et unanime
pour soutenir le peuple iranien comment
accepter par exemple que l'Iran soit
toujours membre de la commission de
l'ONU sur la condition de la femme le
Canada et les États-Unis se sont déjà
prononcés pour une exclusion de l'Iran
de cette commission une hyusienne
qu'attendons-nous la France doit
exalement et également l'exiger vous
avez formulé mesdames et messieurs des
demandes des propositions je vous cite
nommé et condamner ces terroristes des
vies sur les visas des condamnations
leur envoi de l'ambassadeur la
reconnaissance du crime contre
l'humanité toutes ces propositions nous
devons nous en emparer je souhaite
qu'elle prospère je souhaite que la
communauté internationale agit
collectivement pour mettre fin à la
répression les ex à l'encontre du peuple
iranien doivent cesser la France doit
soutenir toute initiative coordonnée au
niveau européen au niveau international
pour y parvenir enfin pour conclure
comment ne pas évoquer la situation des
femmes afghane désespérément seule face
au régime talibans la communauté
internationale ne doit pas faiblir dans
son combat contre l'obscurantisme des
talibans femme vit liberté aux doses de
la des slogans au-delà des déclarations
il faut agir l'engagement et la
détermination du peuple iranien nous
oblige alors si je peux me permettre je
vais reprendre ce magnifique geste de
madame qui est nous a fait un très beau
témoignage tout à l'heure femme vit
liberté
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame merci Madame
voilà merci pour pour vos interventions
merci
particulièrement pour votre courage
ce soir merci et je crois
s'il y a des questions on va pouvoir se
les poser un petit peu plus tard plus
calmement voilà
[Applaudissements]